une campagne des législatives qui bat
son plein à trois jours du premier tour
ce matin valérie pécresse est venue
soutenir françois xavier bellamy
candidats aux élections législatives
dans la première circonscription à la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines la
présidente de la région ile de france a
reconnu les qualités d'élu de terrain du
candidat c'est vrai qu'être député s'est
portée des valeurs et un projet à
l'assemblée nationale mais c'est aussi
défendre un territoire et porter la voix
des habitants de ce territoire
et de ce point de vue être élu local
connaître le territoire y être engagée
depuis des années c'est important et
c'est pour ça que françois xavier a
souhaité que je vienne ici à la gare de
montigny parce qu'un énorme enjeu sur
les transports quand on habite les
yvelines un énorme enjeu de
modernisation un énorme enjeu de
sécurisation et de confort